see far was the brainchild a Fraser
mustard and a group of far thinking
academic and business leaders Fraser and
others at the very beginning and
developed this really visionary idea of
how in Canada you could organize
research in a different way he had this
idea of bringing together people in a
multidisciplinary way to focus on
interesting important questions yeah
this way of convincing many different
people and Faulkner's from different
sectors of society that this was
important and that this would work the
model which we often refer to that
freezer mustard came up with is really a
very very good one this is one of open
and collaborative research it doesn't
just recreate a Economics Department
that's ritual it brings together
economists psychologists sociologists
who focus in on a question not a
discipline I think the countries today
that are going to be successful in the
economies today that are going to be
successful are the ones that are
connected around the world with the best
and brightest minds CFR researchers are
making breakthroughs we know that we see
the law dacians the recognition there's
a direct translation into the realm of
policymaking not just in Canada but
elsewhere in the world I look at the
future and I think about see far I think
of a seed
which was planted 2012 more than 25
years ago and then I started to
germinate and there's this tree which is
coming out and there are all these
branches with these possibility of this
as i look forward over the next you know
30 years and what CFR can bring to the
table not just for scholarly advancement
and scientific advancement but for
society i have no doubt that the
crucible that see far is creating a
bringing together the very best people
from around the world to talk about
important parsons will lead to important
new advances and concepts which will
improve the human condition